hi the things we say and the things
people here aren't always the same the
problem is you can't have agreement
until what somebody hears and what
somebody says are exactly the same so
the question is how do you make sure
that somebody actually heard what you
intended for them to hear ironically it
actually doesn't come from speaking more
and actually comes from speaking less it
actually comes from asking questions the
next time that you engage with somebody
whether it's in a business context or
otherwise and you say something crystal
clear on what you intended to say ask
questions to ensure to feel completely
confident that they heard exactly what
you wanted them to hear and you'll find
that the rest of the negotiation with
the rest of the conversation will be
much easier and much smoother when
you're both playing off of the same
place sheet